the queen
escorted as ancient tradition demands by
the Bishops of Durham and bath and Wells
goes to the altar
there laying her hand upon the Bible
he reaffirms her oath
the late Queen Elizabeth's coronation in
1953 was watched by millions around the
world but our next guest Witnesses
witnessed it firsthand she was there
lady Ann Glenn Connor was personally
chosen as one of the six Maids of honor
at the Queen's coronation she later
served as a lady in waiting to Princess
Margaret that's the Queen's sister of
course lady Ann Glenn Connor writes
about her life in her second Memoir it's
called whatever next now I love that
title now in her ninth decade she calls
her life both extraordinary and
unexpected lady Ann joins us first on
CBS mornings and we welcome you lady Ann
it's good to have you here
what a life you have indeed you're the
mother of five children you said
motherhood was part of the hardest but
one of the most rewarding two of your
children have passed away at one point
one of your sons was in a motorcycle
accident and was in a coma but
Christopher we're glad to say is fine
but I'm fascinated by how you talk about
your marriage you were married for over
50 54 years to a man who was verbally
and physically abused of to you at one
point you lost hearing you still lost
hearing because of of when he beat you
one day and ten years into your marriage
and I like this you said you took a
lover he took a lever and that made your
marriage much better but what I'm
fascinated about is that as as
tumultuous as that marriage was you said
that you don't have regrets but you
don't think that young women should
follow in those footsteps can you talk
about that for a second yes I mean it
was quite difficult I didn't start
writing until I was 87. yes
um and um uh so the first book was
perhaps a bit jokey you know I didn't
quite know how much to put in it and
then I've taught the children and I
thought well I'm 99 I'm just going to
write what I want yes
um and so I wrote this book
um I mean the thing about Colin was that
he was charismatic he was Charming he
was dazzling really and he was dangerous
and that was very hard but I was brought
up I'm quite old and my the way I was
brought up was we didn't give in I did
at one point go back to my mother very
soon all time marriage and said I don't
know if I could cope and she just said
and you you man gym you go straight back
yeah but when you talk to Colin's mother
what did Colin's mother well I tried
calling his mother uh she said darling
of course I know he's a bit different
all you need is a cup of cocoa give him
a cup of cocoa very nice
I know I mean she was in complete denial
and I realized there's no point in but
you have a different message for women
today and I think people should read
that's just one part of the book but the
other part is about your life with the
royal family and you were there for the
Queen's coronation and we're about to
have another coronation coming up yeah
well of course Queen's coronation it's
amazing wonderful day of my life people
often say it was your marriage the most
fun I said well actually it wasn't it
was a coronation that was the most
wonderful and I was so lucky to be
chosen there were only six of us and we
had to be Daughters of Earl's marxists
or Dukes
um and of course why it was so fantastic
the Queen's coronation because we've
just been through a wall I mean there
was rationing there was you know very
little all electric lights no clothes we
had coupons and suddenly this beautiful
young Queen and it was the beginning of
the sort of wonderful Elizabethan age
and people were thrilled and of course
to have such a beautiful queen you knew
her her entire life nearly her entire
life who was she to you oh sorry who was
the queen to you you knew her well I've
always I I you see my parents my father
had been Equity to the Duke of York
before he became king and my mother was
actually lady waiting I knew the Queen
and Princess Margaret when they were
children because we live quite near them
in Norfolk and I remember the first time
I met Princess Morgan I just knew she
was the sort of one that going to be a
naughty wonderful friend and we were and
the queen was always much more serious
you know but she's always looking after
princess Mark she always had an eye art
will we be seeing you at the Kings
coronation which I believe is in May uh
making it two coronation well a lot of
times
out there well I don't know the lovely
big sick Invitational hasn't come
through my letterbox yet but I'm hoping
it will you know it will be fascinating
because
Gary and Megan should be invited I know
yes I mean I I hope they will I mean I
believe they will but whether they come
or not I don't know lady Anglin Connor
Thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate you whatever next is on sale
now wherever you'd like to buy your
books we will be right back